turning now to the pandemic where
president biden ordered american flags
to be flown at half staff yesterday to
mark 1 million coronavirus deaths in
this country members of congress also
held a moment of silence outside the u.s
capitol as new coveted cases continue to
rise all across the country the latest
daily average hit nearly 85 000.
white house coveted response coordinator
dr ashish jaw joins us now to talk about
all of it dr good morning thank you for
being here uh let's talk about cobit
funding we've got 10 billion in funding
held up in the senate right now
if the country doesn't get that money
how vulnerable would you say are we
going to be
yeah good morning tony thanks so much
for having me here um yeah we put in an
emergency request for 22 and a half
billion actually too uh what we thought
was sort of really the bare minimum we
needed to get us through this fall and
winter without that money we're not
going to have enough
of a new generation of vaccines that
americans are going to need this fall
for everybody uh we're going to run out
of treatments we're going to run out of
testing
so it's pretty urgent that congress act
and congress act now so we can be
prepared for what's coming
looking ahead you you said recently that
we could see a hundred million new covet
cases in the fall and winter that's an
eye-popping number a lot of people were
raising their eyebrows and some have
said that maybe that's a politically
motivated number in order to free up
this funding uh where's your data on
that and what do you say to folks who
say you may be playing with the numbers
well first of all uh what i would say is
you know we're looking at a range of
scenarios for planning what we're doing
in the white house is we're planning
both for the summer as well as for the
fall and winter and we're looking at a
range of models both internal as well as
external
and some of them suggest that if we
don't if we go into the fall and winter
with no treatments with no new
generation of vaccines no treatments we
could be looking at a pretty substantial
wave of infections we've had one each of
the last two winters
and we obviously need to be planning for
such scenarios obviously we hope that
doesn't happen obviously we hope
congress steps up and does its job
but we've got a plan for those scenarios
all right let's talk vaccines kids under
five could have a vaccine approved for
them
next month but parents according to
polls are still quite reluctant to
vaccinate kids that young what do you
say to those parents and how important
is vaccinating the the very young to
getting us into the so-called endemic
stage of this pandemic
yeah so in terms of kids under five
we're gonna obviously have to see the
data and what it shows before making a
determination the fda will make that i
will say so far the data on kids and
vaccines has been very very clear i have
three children all of whom are
vaccinated
why because the benefits of vaccines
clearly outweigh the risk these are very
very safe vaccines and they provide a
very high degree of protection i expect
we'll see the same thing for kids under
five we'll see where the data ends but i
really do think that they're very
important for kids to get vaccinated
all right dr ashish jha speaking as a
doctor and as a parent we appreciate it
thank you thank you tony